water game so much hype coming into it  and for both guys to do what they did  was was very impressive women Yama is by  far one of the absolutely nuttiest  prospects that we've ever seen Wendy was  just hitting shot after shot after shot  after shot after shot he's a my player  that you can't even create you cannot  create a seven foot five forward with an  eight foot wingspan on any game you can  look around the league and you can find  a few guys who is similar to scoop you  don't have that with women Yama you have  to look at two three four different  prospects and combine like the best  parts of their game so for him to come  over here play on an NBA three-point  line and go 7-4-11 from long distance uh  look at that off the dribble that's  crazy that's insane off the dribble  contested just just absolutely that's  just silly